et maintenant un rapport qui fait des
vagues la fédération internationale des
droits de l'homme évoquent en des termes
très directs le racisme endémique de la
police française
vous imaginez la suite les syndicats de
policiers crient au scandale pour eux on
utilise des incidents mineurs pour jeter
la suspicion sur toute une profession
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'intérieur
paul quilès montre à son tour au créneau
pour récuser les accusations enquête et
réactions grâce à michel fine et
philippe dumas 6 septembre 90 avenue de
la résistance à montreuil
ibrahima soumah et boubacar et kumar et
rentrer chez eux il est 22h30 un car de
police s'arrête à leur hauteur contrôle
d'identité
le policier est descendu de sa voiture
et celle de petro moi en me disant vos
pièces d'identité je les fais comprendre
que cela pas la façon donc il faut
demander les piscines indiqué aux
citoyens et m'a dit non si je ne m'en
sers je le sors pas les identités qui va
me buter jeudi vers leur but et noir
il me dit si je serai du front national
soumah et kumar et sont alors embarqué
dans le car de police et conduits au
commissariat on m'a mis aussi en cellule
tout nu et à au moins ce plus de dix
policiers qui se sont acharnés sur moi
dans la cellule en me donnant des coups
de coude au point souvent et kumar et
ont porté plainte pour violences
illégitimes la police des polices l'igpn
a été saisie elle a conclu dans son
rapport
les déclarations des plaignants nous ont
semblé parfois outrancière là fère a été
classée quant à ibrahima soumah et s'est
retrouvé devant la justice inculpé de
rébellion
la sphère soumah kumar est aujourd'hui
cité dans le rapport de la fédération
internationale des droits de l'homme sur
le racisme dans la police un
réquisitoire sans nuances qui a
déclenché la colère du ministre de
l'intérieur affirmé comme on le fait
depuis quelques jours sur la base de ce
rapport sur la base de quelques exemples
ponctuelles que je ne mets pas en cause
ils ne sont que des exemples que la
police française serait raciste que la
culture de la police française serait le
racisme se poser la question
sérieusement sans plaisanter
est ce que la france serait encore la
patrie des droits de l'homme
je dis que ce n'est pas raisonnable à
l'image de leur ministre la plupart des
syndicats se sont dits indignés pourtant
certains reconnaissent mais en privé que
trop souvent les policiers font preuve
de comportement raciste
[Musique]